in terms of children entertainment
though can anything ever top Toy Story
Tim Allen the voice of buzz yes time I
saw me was give me an Oscar but the
weird thing is that that is so loved but
children when they see you walking down
the street they don't know there is
countless elevator rides I'll be in the
elevator in a in a mother and child will
get on and the mother will say it's
Woody then the mother tries to explain
Oh their voice is recorded and the actor
who is the voice this is the actor they
the kids just don't get it at all I say
where's the best where's the cowboy hat
you're not very tall and so I say hmm
all right close your eyes like a lot
just just close your eyes or the kid
goes we got to get back to Andy's room
right away guys
can't believe it but for you it must be
lovely to make a film in that way so
that you can watch it like an audience
member oh it's very hard work animating
these films honestly they are because
woody woody he's like this and the
recording sessions go on for four or
five hours so I always come out of
recording Toy Story sessions we're now
recording Toy Story 4 so we were doing
that it'll be a thousand feet as a
matter fact so it takes a long time but
my diaphragm gets a workout because the
entire guys come on but that time I'm
leaving I'm driving home and they
literally have to put an ice chest on my
diaphragm just so I can go home it's
clinch thrill throughout Wow so toy
sorry forward that's active that we are
working on it right now yes oh yeah well
I have a recording session on the 2nd of
December oh I love that noise in the
audience I would somebody stuck a
microphone Abay in my face at some point
something this isn't gonna be a Toy
Story for and I said yeah yeah I think
so and I got a call from the Disney
lawyers the next day said you
contractually are not allowed to discuss
a Toy Story for it will affect the stock
market price of the Disney common stock
so you are no longer at said hey I'm
sorry but let me just point out I'm
woody
boy you're not proud of your lad down
here and pay 42 million books of this
one of these days he just might win an
Oscar